mein name ist meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einer
neuen nicht lachen challenge auf meinem
kanal und heute sogar mit einer
bestrafung denn jedes mal wenn ich
lachen muss muss ich einen wodka trinken
das ist definitiv wodka netz groß
[Musik]
das ist scheiße
warum aber so ein scheiß
neuer bot daher
wie nur kinder
[Musik]
gute erste
clip ohne kinder er ist auch klar was
passiert einfach auf die kamera zu
[Musik]
berechenbar
man kriegt mich nur mit kinder fans
alter
wo warum macht man sowas warum
er will ist einfach dumm
warum machst du so was warum wieder ein
kinderschuh
ja
steißbein
hey
[Musik]
luca
menschlich lage druck werde
remakes notwendig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist einfach die wahrheit apropos und
morgens übrigens meine lieben freunde
gleich aber 18 uhr live auf youtube
kanal spiel mit einigen freunden
online.de
[Musik]
so ist das nämlich ich habe schon lange
nicht mehr gelacht
warum warum das ist doch einfach klar
dass das passiert es ist doch einfach
klar dass das passiert
u
das wird gelaufen
[Musik]
wo
das ist meine schwester gewesen früher
ja aber klar war klar
warum was wollt ihr machen
pro pro ist war einfach nur klar
er ist ein graben und die fallen
wahrscheinlich rhein allerdings sei die
sehr gut und er fällt in den graben
wirklich witzig warum tust du dass du
musst einfach gleich abgerutscht genau
jetzt genau
ja wir sind 25 erwachsene schwere
menschen wir stellen uns jetzt alle
nebeneinander auf denen steht das hält
er bestimmt aus
weniger essen immer so leute die zum
ersten motorrad sitzen und die geben
immer instant vollgas jetzt auch nicht
wo ich kenne es einfach auch bei
techniken
hey ich weiß nicht aber das miteinander
vergleichen kann aber wenn ich da noch
nie fahrrad gefahren bin dann gehe ich
da auch nicht aus farben gibt direkt
vollgas
es regnet und die filmmusik
einfach
ich bin eigentlich recht gut unterwegs
heute
die sind einfach genau gleich aus
alter ist es hier der trailer zu la
bohème
[Applaus]
jetzt damals in der schule mal die hose
gerissen weil ich dachte das wäre cool
mal die hosen voll tief trägt und bin
ich gelaufen über den schulhof
wenn sie sagt sie steht auf männer mit
bart
nein
das bin einfach ich
das
auch traurig spaß machen so der ist
nicht gut also da
ach so
[Musik]
und jedes mal so
die ich je gemacht habe
[Musik]
jesus jesus ist dass wir von dieser
rapper crew
jesus auch stark
wenn man alleine spielen muss
[Musik]
sehr gut
im
public lobbys zusammengefasst hat ein
ihm
auf twitter bist die fünfte
[Musik]
everyone als
immer so immer so ich weiß nicht warum
das so ist aber irgendwie ist rot immer
suspicious im
herzen fällt
auch immer so wenn ich mit sandra im
podcast folge aufnehme sander setz dich
hin und ich sage dann ey du musst du
noch irgendwie ein bierchen holen oder
du musst noch die mutter monika holen
für die fragerunde oder irgendwie so
heute abend kommt übrigens der neue
podcast verordnen um nur aber jedes mal
wenn sandra einmal sind sagt sie einfach
nähe das halt ohne machen wie ich stehe
jetzt nicht noch mal auf einmal weil sie
zu faul ist dann aufzustehen
es war doch so klar
ich glaube in jeder nicht nach
einschätzung von mir bisher mindestens
ein clip drin wo leute in den pool
springen wollten aber vorher
ausgerutscht sind
das sind jungs lachen 900 november
[Musik]
war das im plan sind der ballade
ja was er wollte einfach die leute mit
einer banane abwerfen
ach
der ist für dich
[Musik]
wow
an der stelle ich das heute wieder
beende lieben freunde wenn euch diese
trainer tun lacht challenge mit mir
gefallen hat dann lasst einen daumen
hoch und video.de abonniert haben einen
kanal und wenn ich irgendwann
kommen